From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. When Aetan Hirsch was growing up, newspapers were a central part of the family's daily routine. If you were a member of the household, you kept up with the news. My parents raised me and my siblings in a politically engaged environment. At least I thought so, you know, we always were, we knew what was going on in the news, the newspaper was delivered to our home. we always were, we knew what was going on in the news, the newspaper was delivered to our home. After Aetan went off to college, his father kept reading, listening to the radio, staying up to speed. And then a few years ago, Aetan learned that his dad had developed a new habit. He would lie on his bed at night and watch cable news.
来自NPR，这里是隐秘大脑，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当埃坦·赫希（Aetan Hirsch）长大的时候，报纸是他们家庭日常生活核心的一部分。如果你是这个家庭的一员，你就会关注新闻。我的父母在一个积极参与政治的环境中抚养我和我的兄弟姐妹。至少我是这么认为的，你知道的，我们总是这样，我们知道新闻里在发生什么，报纸会送到我们家里。我们总是这样，我们知道新闻里在发生什么，报纸会送到我们家里。埃坦上大学离家后，他的父亲仍然坚持读书、听收音机，紧跟时事。几年后，埃坦得知他的父亲养成了一个新习惯。他晚上会躺在床上看有线新闻。
Out front next breaking news, Trump's tantrum, a jaw-dropping stage. Eton, now a political scientist, found this puzzling. I've never really personally gotten into cable news. It's never been something I've enjoyed. I asked him why I was doing it, and he said, you know, it's our duty to be informed. And I said to him, you've already already are informed.
前方突发新闻，特朗普的脾气，令人目瞪口呆的舞台。埃坦现在是一名政治学家，他觉得这很令人费解。我个人从来没有真正迷上过有线新闻。它从来都不是我喜欢的东西。我问他为什么要这么做，他说，你知道的，了解信息是我们的责任。我对他说，你已经了解信息了。
You know, you've already read the newspaper. You've already listened to all the radio. Well, possibly more could you be getting from this? I think in the end it was pretty clear that he just likes politics, a lot of people like politics, and to decompress that night, you know, more than the food network, the Kardashians, whatever else is on TV, he likes watching cable news. Millions of Americans are like eight-hounds dad. They eagerly follow television personalities and the ups and downs of the latest scandal
你知道的，你已经读过报纸了。你已经听过所有的收音机了。好吧，你还能从中得到什么呢？我认为最后很明显，他只是喜欢政治，很多人都喜欢政治，为了在晚上放松一下，你知道的，比起美食频道、卡戴珊家族或电视上的其他内容，他更喜欢看有线新闻。数百万美国人和埃坦的父亲一样。他们热切地追随电视名人和华盛顿最新丑闻的起伏。
in Washington. Nearly a month after the house passed too late. It's two weeks since the RRC TV star Kim Kardashian was. These two departments have been watching. The CNN tonight, Don Leman starts now. They know who testified last week on Capitol Hill. Ten small minutes in the room between Democrats and Republicans. How was that? The news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the
在众议院通过该法案近一个月后，已经太迟了。距离RRC电视明星金·卡戴珊被……已经过去两周了。这两个部门一直在关注。今晚的CNN，唐·莱蒙现在开始。他们知道谁上周在国会山作证了。民主党和共和党人在房间里待了短短十分钟。感觉怎么样？新闻是……
news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that
新闻是……
the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news is that the news government. He wasn't in the FBI. Gentlemen, I have to jump in here. I love this debate here, but we have to go to a short break after that.
新闻是……政府。他不在联邦调查局。各位，我得插一句了。我很喜欢这里的辩论，但在此之后我们必须进入一个短暂的休息。
Short break will continue our discussion. Unstill, more Washington scandals. If you ask them why they follow the news so closely, they will tell you what Aetans father told him. It's an act of civic virtue to stay informed. Aetan Hirsch is skeptical and he has the data to prove it. He argues provocatively that what his dad is doing isn't really about politics or policy or elections. It's really just about his dad. What feels right to him?
短暂休息后我们将继续我们的讨论。还有更多的华盛顿丑闻。如果你问他们为什么如此密切地关注新闻，他们会告诉你埃坦的父亲告诉他的话。保持知情是一种公民美德。埃坦·赫希对此持怀疑态度，并且他有数据来证明这一点。他挑衅性地辩称，他父亲所做的事情其实并不是关于政治、政策或选举的。其实这只是关于他父亲自己的事。什么对他来说感觉是对的？
It seems to me that the way that people are doing politics is much more similar to a hobby than to what I think of a politics, which is, you know, acquiring power. Today we look at a strange twist of modern politics in the United States. We live in a 24-7 cycle of political news that saturates every corner of our culture. It seems like this is led to increased engagement in politics. But Eitan Hirsch says that engagement with politics for many of us has actually become more shallow. As a result, he says, our democracy from the workings of
在我看来，人们参与政治的方式更像是一种爱好，而不是我所认为的政治——也就是，你知道的，获取权力。今天我们来看看美国现代政治的一个奇怪转折。我们生活在一个24小时不间断的政治新闻周期中，它充斥着我们文化的每一个角落。这似乎导致了对政治的参与度增加。但埃坦·赫希表示，我们许多人对政治的参与实际上变得更加肤浅。结果，他说，我们的民主——从城市政府的运作到总统宝座的争夺——越来越远离公民的实际需求。我们对政治的热情背后的悖论，本周在“隐秘大脑”播出。本周在“隐秘大脑”播出。埃坦·赫希是塔夫茨大学的政治学家。他研究投票、选举以及我们如何参与政治。在他的书《政治是争取权力的工具》（Politics is for Power）中，埃坦指出，数百万美国人参与政治的方式在情感上是满足的，但最终却是自我挫败的。他们这样做是为了满足自己的情感和智力需求。
city government to the battle for the presidency is increasingly distant from the actual needs of citizens. The paradox of our passion for politics this week on Hidden Brain. this week on Hidden Brain. Aetan Hirsch is a political scientist at Tufts University. He studies voting, elections, and how we participate in politics. In his book, Politics is for power. Aetan makes the case that millions of Americans are engaging in politics in ways that are emotionally satisfying, but ultimately self-defeating. They're there to serve their own emotional
他们并没有试图感动任何人。他们也没有试图赋予任何东西权力。他们真的只是在以一种相当轻率的方式学习和参与。因此，我想象很多听你节目的人会不同意你对他们的评估。我想很多人会说，我从共和党的滑稽动作或民主党的顽固中得不到任何乐趣。事实上，我们的政治现状让我一直感到筋疲力尽和沮丧。我想这是对的。有些人可能会同意，你知道的，整天挂在推特上或分享关于一些愚蠢新闻故事的梗图是一种娱乐，但他们带入政治的情感要深刻得多。他们在乎。当政治没有按照他们希望的方向发展时，他们会感到受伤。
and intellectual needs. They're not trying to move anyone. They're not trying to empower anything. They're really just trying to learn and engage in a pretty frivolous way. So I would imagine that a lot of people listening to you would disagree with your assessment of them. I think a lot of people would say, I derive no entertainment from the shenanigans
当政治确实朝着他们想要的方向发展时，他们会感到喜悦。问题是，他们实际所做的事情并没有以任何积极的方式参与其中。他们真的只是在关注新闻。他们关注总统初选周期的起伏、穆勒报告或弹劾听证会，因此他们自己并没有参与。你引入了一个我在政治语境中实际上没听过的词。你说人们实际上是在追求一种爱好。他们是为了那种感觉、辩论的刺激、得分而参与其中的，你称这些人为主业爱好者（hobbyists）。你这个词是什么意思？是的，所以我顺便读了一些关于爱好的社会学文献。
of the Republicans or the intransigence of the Democrats. In fact, I feel exhausted and disperited by the state of our politics all the time. I think that's right. Some people probably would agree that, you know, being on Twitter all the time or sharing a meme about some silly news story is entertainment, but the feelings that they bring to politics are much deeper. They care. And they feel hurt that politics isn't going the way they want it.
什么是爱好？人们做的事情要么是为了学习事实，他们学习关于历史的事实，他们学习关于鸟类的事实，无论他们想要什么，要么他们是在收集材料，他们参与某种手艺。在我看来，人们参与政治的方式更像是一种爱好，而不是我所认为的政治——也就是获取权力。所以他们会了解很多事实并谈论这些事实。他们会参与某种手艺。就像他们会上网分享梗图、进行讨论，这非常类似于体育迷，你知道的，听体育广播，他们会谈论这个四分卫或那个四分卫在做什么的八卦，事情差不多就到此为止了。
And they feel joy when politics does go the way they want it. The thing is that what they're actually doing is not participating themselves in any active way. They're really just following the news. They're following the ups and downs of a presidential primary cycle or the Mueller report or the impeachment hearings, and so they themselves are not participating. You introduced a word that I hadn't actually heard in the context of politics. You said that people are really pursuing a hobby. They're in it for the fields, the thrill of debate, scoring points, and you call these people hobbyists. What do you mean by the term? Yeah, so I was kind of reading through some of the sociology literature on hobbies.
而政治，我认为这正是人们也在做的事情。如果我们把政治参与定义为一种参与形式，即你试图将公共政策或选举政治推向你在乎的方向，你投下你的一票，并说服另一个人按照你的意愿投票或按照你的意愿进行倡导。这确实不能描述大多数人在做政治时的行为。它看起来更像他们所做的事情类似于体育狂热分子参与体育运动，或者美食家观看美食节目、阅读餐馆评论。它似乎更属于生活的那一类，而不是权力获取的那一类。所以当我想到一种爱好或成为一个体育迷时，我想到了那些从正在发生的事情中获得巨大满足感或巨大挫败感的人，他们充满激情地参与其中，但最终他们不得不承认他们的参与没有什么影响。是的。如果他们想真正认真地参与政治，他们会以完全不同的方式去做。而不是痛恨另一方，
And what are hobbies? Things that are people doing either to learn learning facts, they learn facts about history, they learn facts about birds, whatever they want, or they're engaging in collecting materials, they're engaged in kind of crafts. And it seemed to me that the way that people are doing politics is much more similar to a hobby than to what I think of a politics, which is acquiring power. So they will learn a lot of facts and talk about those facts. They will participate in a kind of craft. Like they'll go online and share memes, have a discussion, very similar to how sports fans, you know, listen to sports radio, they'll talk about the gossip of, you know, what this quarterback or that quarterback is doing, and that's sort of the end of it.
而不是痛恨一个自称是共和党人或自称是民主党人的随机路人，他们会说，嗯，这是我可以说到并朝着我的方向转变的邻居吗？当我们与那些每天都在基层努力说服其他人加入他们的组织者交谈时，他们并不讨厌另一方。对他们来说，这完全是错误的参考框架。他们思考的是，我如何说服一个人？
And politics, I think that's exactly what people are doing, too. If we define political participation as a form of engagement where you are trying to move public policy or electoral politics in a direction you care about, you have your one vote and you're convincing another person to vote the way you want or to advocate the way you want. That really doesn't describe the behavior of what most people are doing when they're doing politics. It looks much more like what they're
可能会有另一边的人说他们是共和党人而我是民主党人，或者说他们是民主党人而我是民主党人，或者说他们是民主党人而我是共和党人。我的第一反应是，呃，他们相信所有这些我认为是卑鄙的事情。但我的第二个反应，如果我真的在乎去说服他们，是他们关心什么是我也关心的，我可以利用这一点把他们拉到我的方向？而在体育迷中以及人们参与党派粉丝的那种肤浅方式中，这第二步从未发生过。从来没有一个目标去说服洋基队的球迷来支持红袜队。这并不重要。如果你在网上，或者只和那些和你完全一样的人谈论政治，那就没有必要把另一个政党的人看作是需要你向其证明或说服任何事情的人。你不需要。
doing is similar to a sports fanatic engaged in sports or a foodie watching food shows, reading restaurant reviews. It seems much more in that category of life than in the category of power acquisition. So when I think about a hobby or I think about being a sports fan, I think about people who derive, you know, great satisfaction or great frustration from what's happening, the engage in it passionately, but ultimately they'd have to acknowledge that their involvement has little consequence. That's right. If they wanted to actually participate in politics seriously, they would go about this all differently. Instead of hating the other side,
你不需要说服他们任何事情，因为你什么也没做。如果你是一个红袜队的球迷，当然，你正是从与志同道合的人之间的那种同志情谊中获得满足感，而不是去接触那些可能真正处于回音室之外的人。是的。我喜欢成为一个红袜队的球迷。你知道的，正如我在书中说的，我就住在芬威球场附近，我曾去过芬威球场并带我的孩子去那里，芬威的整个球场都会一遍又一遍地高呼洋基队真逊，洋基队真逊，他们几十年来一直这样做，这一切都有点像个玩笑，因为赌注很低，我们并不是真的讨厌那些洋基队的球迷或洋基队的球员，这只是一场游戏，对很多人来说，成为其中的一部分很有趣。那么，如何解释这样一个事实：在政治中，人们不认为它很有趣？我的意思是，如果你是一个民主党人，你认为共和党人很糟糕，或者你是一个共和党人，你认为民主党人很糟糕，你不会把它当成一场游戏，你认为它是极其严肃的，那是政治
instead of hating a random person who says they're a public and who says they're a Democrat, they would say, hmm, is this a neighbor that I can convince to move in my direction? And when we talk to organizers who are out every day in the trenches trying to convince other people to come along with them, they don't hate the other side. It's like totally the wrong frame of reference for them. They're thinking about, how do I move a person?
业余爱好者的表现吗？什么是政治业余爱好，不是指你认为它极其严肃与否。而是指这种情感本身就是目的，还是达到目的的手段。所以在快捷政治和业余爱好中，情感才是目标。它让你感觉自己与某事相连，而无需自己做任何事情。它让我觉得自己是这种情感高潮的一部分，或者我是这个悲伤时刻、这个低谷的一部分，尽管我什么也没做。我只是在关注它，但情感就是连接。当然，我们有一整套媒体机构和社交媒体机构来让我们感受到这些情感。但在现实政治中，愤怒、正义的愤怒和情感是你转化为行动的筹码。如果没有第二步，你可能会觉得自己有政治和党派的思想，但你并没有有效地将它们引导到其他任何事情上去。所以我想检验你对这些说法的更广泛的证据，我想从你讲述的关于你家乡马萨诸塞州两次选举的一个富有启示性的故事开始。第一次是在2008年，主角是竞选总统的巴拉克·奥巴马，第二次是在14个月后，是一场对参议院权力平衡具有重大影响的参议院席位特别选举。告诉我这两场比赛中发生了什么。所以在2008年的马萨诸塞州，马萨诸塞州是一个蓝州。
There might be a person on the other side who says they're Republican and I'm a Democrat or says they're Democrat and I'm a Democrat or says they're Democrat and I'm Republican. And my first reaction is, ugh, they believe all these things I think are despicable. But my second reaction, if I really care about moving them, is what do they care about that I care about, that I can leverage to move them in my direction? And in sports fandom and in the kind of shallow way that people engaged in partisan fandom, that second step is never made. There's never a goal to convince a Yankee fan
巴拉克·奥巴马和约翰·麦凯恩之间谁会赢得选举，这从来都不是一个问题。然而，很多人都很活跃，很多人都投票了。我们预计参议员奥巴马将在马萨诸塞州获胜。NSE 11名选举人。马萨诸塞州的投票率非常高，就像美国其他地方一样，对于这次总统选举，
to come to the Red Sox. It doesn't matter. And if you're online, or only talking about politics to people who are exactly like you, there's no point of thinking of a person on the other political party as someone you need to convince of anything. You don't.
但在马萨诸塞州并不是一场势均力敌的较量。几个月后，民主党控制了众议院。他们以60个席位控制了参议院，这对于冗长辩论（filibuster）很重要，他们控制了白宫。但现在，它没那么令人兴奋了，有一场参议院竞选即将到来，这是一场特别的参议院竞选，以取代泰德·肯尼迪生前占有的席位。他去世了。这个席位在共和党人斯科特·布朗和民主党人玛莎·科克利之间展开。现在马萨诸塞州有机会真正利用其投票的热情去做一件真正重要的事情。现在马萨诸塞州真的很重要，因为这结果是一场势均力敌的选举，民主党在参议院的60个席位控制权危在旦besie。发生了什么？在州里，民主党对共和党保持着三比一的优势，但GOP（共和党）候选人斯科特·布朗展开了积极的竞选，他在民调中表现不错，对阵民主党总检察长玛莎·科克利。
You don't need to convince them of anything because you're not doing anything. And if you're a Red Sox fan, of course, you are deriving satisfaction precisely from the camaraderie you have with like-minded people as opposed to reaching out to people who might actually be outside the echo chamber. That's right. I love being a Red Sox fan. And you know, as I say in the book, I live right near
从巴拉克·奥巴马在马萨诸塞州的那场压倒性胜利，到这场非常重要的参议院选举，投票率急剧下降，在民主党高度集中的地区尤其下降。所以，当马萨诸塞州的民主党人真正到了这样一个时刻：你知道吗，尽管现在的政治对民主党来说可能处于低谷，也许我们参议院席位的候选人没有巴拉克·奥巴马那么令人兴奋。我们要坚持到底，因为我们真的很在乎掌握权力。相反，他们坐在家里。我感谢马萨诸塞州人民选举我作为你们的下一任美国参议员。斯科特·布朗赢得了那场选举。
Fenway Park, I've gone to Fenway Park and taken my children there and the whole park at Fenway will chant Yankee Suck, Yankee Suck, over and over again, they've done it for decades now and it's all kind of a joke because the stakes are low, we don't really hate those people who are the Yankees fans or the Yankees players it's a game and it's fun to be part of it for a lot of people so what explains the fact that in politics people don't think of it as being fun i mean if you're a democrat and you think republicans are terrible or your republican and you think democrats are terrible you don't think of it as a as a game you think of it as being deadly serious is that political
因此，如果你只愿意在有名人或真正能吸引你兴奋的人出现时才去投票，那么在党派处于低谷、候选人没那么令人兴奋但政策同样重要的时候，你就不会做得很好。你还讲了另一个关于马萨诸塞州的故事，这个故事发生在2019年。民主党人要求学生去新罕布什尔州拉票，或者甚至只是在本地拉票，而在另一个场合，学生们被问及是否想进行一次公路旅行去见民主党总统候选人皮特·布蒂吉格。每个案例中都发生了什么？
hobbyism to what's political hobbyism is is not, you think of it as being deadly serious. Is that political hobbyism too? What's political hobbyism is not whether you think it's deadly serious or not. It's whether the emotion is the ended itself or a means to an end. So in shortcut politics and hobbyism, emotion is the goal. It makes you feel connected to something without doing anything yourself. It makes me feel I am part of this emotional high or I am part of this sad point, this low point, even though I'm not doing anything. I'm just following it, but the emotion is the connection. And of course, we have a whole media apparatus and social media apparatus to make us feel those emotions. But in real politics, anger, righteous anger and emotion are something you leverage into action. If there's no second step there, you might feel like you're feeling
是的，我在塔夫茨大学校园里的民主党人。他们在校园里举办一些活动，但他们非常努力地争取学生和他们一起去新罕布什尔州拉票。学生们告诉他们，你知道的，太远了。我们不能去新罕布什尔州。我们有课。我们有事情要做。所以在2018年的选举中，他们从来没有召集到超过七个学生坐车去新罕布什尔州，顺便说一句，那里大概只有一个小时的车程，去拉票。然后故事是这样的，呃，在新罕布什尔州曼彻斯特有一个皮特·布蒂吉格的活动。所以学生民主党人说，好吧，
political and partisan thoughts, but you're not channeling them effectively into anything else. So I want to examine your larger evidence for these claims, and I want to start with a revealing story you tell about two elections in your home state of Massachusetts. The first was in 2008, and it featured Barack Obama running for president, and the second, 14 months later, featured a special election for a Senate seat that had big implications for the balance of power in the Senate. Tell me what happened in those two races. So in 2008 and Massachusetts, Massachusetts is a blue state.
政治和党派观点，但你并没有将其有效地转化为其他任何东西。因此，我想检验你对这些说法的更广泛证据，我想从你讲述的一个关于你的家乡马萨诸塞州两场选举的富有启发性的故事开始。第一场是在2008年，巴拉克·奥巴马竞选总统；第二场在14个月后，是一场参议院席位的特别选举，这对参议院的权力和平衡具有重大影响。告诉我这两场竞选中发生了什么。所以，在2008年的马萨诸塞州，马萨诸塞州是一个蓝州。
There was never going to be a question of who was going to win the election between Barack Obama and John McCain. Nevertheless, a lot of people were active and a lot of people voted. We project that Senator Obama will carry the state of Massachusetts. NSE 11 electives. Very high turnout in Massachusetts, like in the rest of the country, for this presidential election,
巴拉克·奥巴马和约翰·麦凯恩之间谁会赢得选举，从来都不是一个问题。尽管如此，许多人依然积极参与，很多人投了票。我们预计奥巴马参议员将赢得马萨诸塞州，获得11张选举人票。马萨诸塞州的投票率非常高，就像全国其他地方一样，在这场总统选举中，
that in Massachusetts wasn't a close call. A few months later, the Democrats have control of the house. They have control of the Senate with 60 seats, which was important for the filibuster, and they have control of the White House. But now, it's not so exciting, and there's a Senate race that comes, a special Senate race to replace the seat that Ted Kennedy held. He passed away. And the seat was
在马萨诸塞州并不是一个悬念。几个月后，民主党控制了众议院。他们以60个席位控制了参议院，这对于打破冗长辩论至关重要，并且他们控制了白宫。但现在，事情没那么激动人心了，有一场参议院选举即将到来，这是一场特别的参议院选举，以填补泰德·肯尼迪生前持有的席位。他去世了。这个席位是
between Scott Brown or Republican and Martha Cogley, a Democrat. Now here Massachusetts had a chance to really leverage its excitement for voting for something that really mattered. Now Massachusetts really mattered because this turned out to be a close election and the Democrats control of 60 seats in the Senate was on the line. What happened? Democrats hold a three to one advantage over Republicans in the state, but the GOP candidates Scott Brown has waged an energetic campaign, and he's pulling well against the Democrat Attorney General Martha Cochley.
在共和党人斯科特·布朗和民主党人玛莎·科克利之间展开。现在，马萨诸塞州有机会真正利用其投票的热情去做真正重要的事情。马萨诸塞州现在真的很重要，因为这演变成了一场势均力敌的选举，民主党在参议院的60个席位控制权危在旦夕。发生了什么？民主党在州内的优势是共和党的3比1，但共和党候选人斯科特·布朗展开了充满活力的竞选，他与民主党总检察长玛莎·科克利的民调势均力敌。
From the, not close, the, you know, from the, from the landslide Massachusetts election for Barack Obama, to the really important Senate election, turnout dropped precipitously, and it especially dropped in highly democratic areas. So when there was really a moment for Democrats and Massachusetts to say, you know what, even though politics right now, maybe is down for the Democrats, maybe the candidate for our Senate seat is not as exciting as Barack Obama. We're going to come through because we really care about holding power. Instead, they sat at home. I thank the people of Massachusetts for our electing me as your next United States senator. It's got around one that election.
从那场毫无悬念的、你知道的、从巴拉克·奥巴马在马萨诸塞州的大胜，到这场极其重要的参议院选举，投票率急剧下降，在极度民主党的地区尤其如此。因此，当马萨诸塞州的民主党人和人们真正需要站出来说，你知道的，尽管现在的政治对民主党来说可能处于低谷，也许我们参议院席位的候选人没有巴拉克·奥巴马那么令人兴奋。我们要挺身而出，因为我们真的很在乎掌握权力。相反，他们坐在家里。我感谢马萨诸塞州人民选举我为你们下一任美国参议员。斯科特·布朗赢得了那场选举。
And so if you're only willing to vote when there's a celebrity or someone who really is drawing you in to the excitement, then you're going to not do so well in the down times when the chips are down for your party, the candidates aren't as exciting, but the policy matters just as much. There's another story you tell about Massachusetts, and this one took place in 2019. Democrats asked students to go up to New Hampshire to canvas, or even just to canvas locally, and on another occasion, the students were asked if they wanted to take a road trip to meet Democratic presidential candidate Pete Buttigieg. What happened in each case?
因此，如果你只愿意在有名人或真正能吸引你进入激情时刻的人出现时才去投票，那么当你的政党处于低谷、时运不济时，你就会表现不佳，候选人没那么令人兴奋，但政策同样重要。你还讲了另一个关于马萨诸塞州的故事，这个故事发生在2019年。民主党人要求学生去新罕布什尔州进行拉票，甚至只是在当地拉票，还有一次，学生们被问及是否想去公路旅行，会见民主党总统候选人皮特·布蒂吉格。每个案例中都发生了什么？
Yes, so the Democrats at my college campus had toughs. They do some events on campus, but they try really hard to get students to come with them to canvas in New Hampshire. And the students told them, you know, it's just too far away. We can't go to New Hampshire. We have classes. We have stuff to do. And so in the 2018 election, they never got more than seven students to get in a car to New Hampshire, which by the way, is like an hour away, um, to Canvas. And then the story goes that, um, there was a Pete Buttigieg event in Manchester, New Hampshire. And so the student dems said, okay, well,
是的，我所在大学校园里的民主党人有塔夫茨分校。他们在校园里举办一些活动，但他们非常努力地让学生和他们一起去新罕布什尔州拉票。学生们告诉他们，你知道的，太远了。我们不能去新罕布什尔州。我们有课。我们有很多事要做。因此，在2018年的选举中，他们从来没有召集到超过七名学生坐车去新罕布什尔州，顺便说一句，那里大约有一个小时的车程，嗯，去拉票。然后故事是，嗯，在新罕布什尔州曼彻斯特有一个皮特·布蒂吉格的活动。所以学生民主党人说，好吧，
does anyone want to come up to Manchester to meet Pete Buttigieg? We can take a selfie with them, post it on Instagram. And the student democratic group could not find enough cars to accommodate all of the tough students who wanted to go and take a selfie with Pete people to judge.
有人想去曼彻斯特见皮特·布蒂吉格吗？我们可以和他自拍，发到Instagram上。而学生民主党组织竟然找不到足够多的车来容纳所有想去和皮特·布蒂吉格自拍的塔夫茨学生。
So perhaps the most elementary difference between those who think of politics as a means to power, as a means to affect policy, and those who think of it as an entertaining diversion is whether people show up to vote. I understand that you've run surveys where you ask people whether they voted and then you compare what they tell you to records showing whether they actually voted. What do you find? So a lot of people, like almost half sometimes, have confirmed non-voters. That is people who the public record shows they did not vote. About half of them sometimes say they voted even when they didn't.
因此，把政治视为争取权力的手段、影响政策的手段的人，与把政治视为娱乐消遣的人之间，最根本的区别也许就是人们是否会去投票。据我了解，你做过这样的调查：你询问人们是否投过票，然后将他们的回答与显示他们是否实际投票的记录进行对比。你发现了什么？许多人，有时几乎有一半，是被确认没有投票的人。也就是说，公共记录显示他们没有投票。其中大约有一半人有时会说他们投了票，即使他们根本没投。
And when a colleague and I tried to figure out who are the kinds of people that lie about voting, we discovered essentially college educated news followers lie a lot. When they don't vote, they say they voted anyway. Another piece of evidence you have about the rise of political hobbyism is a decline in interest in any election that is not about national issues or national candidates. Can you talk about this for a moment? How has interest in local elections, like mayoral races, for example,
当我和一位同事试图弄清楚究竟是哪类人会在投票这件事上撒谎时，我们发现基本上是受过大学教育的新闻关注者在大量撒谎。当他们没有投票时，他们会说自己投了票。你关于政治业余爱好主义兴起的另一个证据是，人们对任何不涉及国家议题或国家候选人的选举的兴趣都在下降。你能谈谈这个吗？近年来，人们对地方选举（如市长竞选）的兴趣是如何变化的，
how has that changed in recent years, even as people have paid increasingly close attention to what's happening on the national stage? So a big part of that story's got to be the media, right? The media landscape is dramatically different. There's a lot fewer resources in local news and local newspapers declining rates of engagement with even TV, local news. And there's a question about whether that's, you know, how the supply and demand chain
尽管人们越来越密切地关注国家层面的事情，这种情况是如何改变的？所以这背后的很大一部分原因一定是媒体，对吧？媒体环境发生了巨大的变化。地方新闻和地方报纸的资源要少得多，人们连电视地方新闻的参与率也在下降。这里有一个问题，那就是，你知道的，这是供需链，
or the cause and effect relationship between interest and local news and availability of local news. But what's happened is that we have very, very few people voting locally and taking interest in what's happening in state and local politics. And so you have people say on the left to say, I really care about the environment or I really care about racial equality. But I'm not going to pay attention to the ways my state or city might work on those issues. I'm not going to apply any pressure to my state legislator to work on those issues because what's happening at the state and local levels kind
或者是对地方新闻的兴趣与地方新闻可用性之间的因果关系。但发生的情况是，我们在地方选举中投票的人非常少，对州和地方政治中发生的事情感兴趣的人也非常少。因此，你看到左翼人士说，我真的很关心环境，或者我真的很关心种族平等。但我不会去关注我的州或城市可能会如何处理这些问题。我不会向我的州议员施加任何压力去处理这些问题，因为发生在州和地方层面的事情有点
of boring and it's just not as exciting as President Trump's tweets. And on the right, you see the same thing, but not as much. On the left, there's been this long history of particularly the kind of the well-educated wing of the Democratic Party poo-pooing what's happening at the state and local levels saying, no, all the interesting stuff has got to be the national stuff. So, you're pointing to something really interesting, which is that political hobbyists might be found in all parties, but there are important differences between the parties,
无聊，而且根本不如特朗普总统的推特那么令人兴奋。而在右翼，你也会看到同样的情况，但没那么严重。在左翼，一直有这样一段悠久的历史，特别是民主党中受过良好教育的那一翼，对发生在州和地方层面的事情不屑一顾，他们说，不，所有有趣的事情都必须是国家层面的事情。所以，你指出了一个非常有趣的事情，那就是政治业余爱好者可能存在于所有政党中，但政党之间存在重要差异，
but also in other fronts, you find that political hobbyists are not distributed equally across the spectrum between men and women or between the rich and poor. Can you talk about those differences for a moment? Sure, so first of all, when you look at groups on both parties, particularly on the left, that are involved in community organizing, that are involved in party committees and groups, you see it's mostly women. If you go to any of the indivisible groups which are popped up since the Trump election, it's about two-thirds women. But when you are online or you survey people about how interested they are in politics,
而且在其他方面，你会发现政治业余爱好者在男女之间或贫富之间的光谱上并不是均匀分布的。你能谈谈这些差异吗？当然，首先，当你看看两个政党的群体，特别是在左翼，那些参与社区组织、参与政党委员会和团体的群体，你会发现大多数是女性。如果你去任何自特朗普当选以来涌现出的“不可分割”组织，大约三分之二都是女性。但当你在网上或通过调查了解人们对政治的兴趣时，
how many facts they know about politics, that's predominantly men. You also see this phenomenon that, you know, if you look at, like, if you, you know, when I survey people and say, how much time are you spending on politics? You see the most time people are spending politics is among college educated white men. And part of the story there is a racial story that like African Americans and Latinos in the Democratic Party are spending less time, say thinking, reading about politics,
他们对政治了解多少事实，那主要是男性。你还会看到这样一种现象，你知道的，如果你看一下，比如，如果你，你知道的，当我调查人们并询问他们花多少时间在政治上时？你会发现人们花在政治上最多时间的是受过大学教育的白人男性。这背后的部分原因是种族问题，就像民主党内的非裔美国人和拉丁裔花在政治上的时间较少，比如思考、阅读政治方面的内容，
but much more time engaged in community organizations than college educated white liberals. And the story behind that is about how satisfied you are with the status quo. And the folks who were pretty satisfied with the status quo talked a lot about important things, civil rights and so forth, but were much less engaged in empowerment. When we come back, the powerful implications of political hobbyism on both the left and the right. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. I'm talking today with political scientist Aetan Hirsh about the millions of Americans who engage in politics as a form of self-expression rather than as a mechanism for real change.
但花在社区组织上的时间要比受过大学教育的白人自由派多得多。这背后的故事关乎你对现状的满意程度。那些对现状相当满意的人谈论了很多重要的事情，比如民权等等，但对赋权的参与度要低得多。广告回来后，我们将探讨政治业余爱好主义对左右翼产生的深远影响。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天我与政治学家埃坦·赫尔希一起讨论数百万将政治作为自我表达形式，而不是作为真正变革机制的美国人。
Aetan says there is one central difference between hobbyists and people who are serious about getting stuff done. The serious people are less interested in how they feel and more interested in acquiring and using power. Eitan Metaman who was serious about that kind of power in the Boston area, he was known locally as the Ukrainian boss. So this man was a mystery to me. Someone told me there is this elderly man living in this neighborhood of Boston called
埃坦说，业余爱好者与那些认真做事的人之间有一个核心区别。认真的人对自己的感觉兴趣较少，而对获取和使用权力更感兴趣。埃坦遇到了一位在波士顿地区对这种权力认真的男士，他在当地被称为“乌克兰老大”。所以这个人对神秘的我来说是个谜。有人告诉我，在波士顿这个叫
Brighton who was somehow a boss that he controlled a thousand votes and I really wanted to figure out like who was this person, how do you control a thousand votes? So I asked if I can meet him. This man his name is Nock. He came to the United States from the former USSR, from Ukraine, and he was a leader in a retirement community of mostly older Russian Jews in this neighborhood in Brighton. He was like one of the, you know,
布赖顿的街区里，住着一位老年男子，他不知怎么地是个老大，他控制了一千张选票，我真的很想弄清楚这个人是谁，你是怎么控制一千张选票的？所以我问我能不能见他。这个人名叫诺克。他从前苏联的乌克兰来到美国，他是布赖顿这个街区里主要是老年俄罗斯犹太人退休社区的领袖。他就像其中一个，你知道的，
he organized community events. But in the 90s, Congress and President Clinton passed a welfare reform bill. And in the original law, legal immigrants, including those living in old age homes, were going to be turned away from benefits like food stamps or disability. And this was a major problem because for the folks living in Knox building and for many retired communities throughout the country, this was the main source of their food. And so there was panic.
他组织社区活动。但在90年代，国会和克林顿总统通过了一项福利改革法案。在最初的法律中，合法移民（包括住在养老院的移民）将被剥夺食品券或残疾补助等福利。这是一个重大问题，因为对于住在诺克大楼里的人以及全国许多退休社区的人来说，这是他们食物的主要来源。所以当时充满了恐慌。
the main source of their food. And so there was panic. And Nah, as the community leader, he started to advocate a little bit going on radio, doing some interviews. But he and his wife started to try to get as many people citizenship as quickly as they can. So a lot of the people were eligible for citizenship, but their English wasn't great.
他们食物的主要来源。所以当时充满了恐慌。而作为社区领袖的诺克，开始进行一些倡导活动，上电台，做一些采访。但他和他的妻子开始尽其所能，尽可能快地为尽可能多的人办入籍手续。所以很多人符合入籍条件，但他们的英语不是很好。
They had to practice for this, you know, 20 questions on the test about the Bill of Rights and stuff like that. They had to be able to write a sentence, talk to someone. And so, knock on his wife, trained all these people to take the citizenship test, and in a couple years, they got 300 of their neighbors citizenship. I do mind to declare that I'm a student. there. Soon after he decided to leverage his central point in this community for politics. He learned that someone who's in a state legislative office or on the city council can do a lot for this community who care about certain policies like immigration, but they also care about transportation issues, getting the snow shoveled to their building.
他们为此不得不进行练习，你知道的，测试中有关于权利法案等内容的20个问题。他们必须能够写出一个句子，与人交谈。因此，诺克和他的妻子训练了所有人参加公民考试，在几年内，他们让300名邻居加入了美国国籍。我在此宣誓，我是一个学生。在那里不久后，他决定利用他在这个社区中的核心地位来搞政治。他了解到，担任州立法机构办公室职务或市议会成员的人可以为这个关心某些政策（如移民）的社区做很多事情，但他们也关心交通问题，比如为他们的建筑铲雪。
And so, Nah and his so-called lieutenants started filling out a sample ballot. They would get a sample ballot. They would mark who they thought the community should vote for. They make photocopies, and they'd hand it out in their building. The building has about 1,000 people in it. The precinct voting booths are actually in the building itself.
因此，诺克和他的所谓副手开始填写样本选票。他们会拿到一张样本选票。他们会标出他们认为社区应该投票给谁。他们复印选票，并在他们的建筑里分发。这栋楼里大约有1,000人。 precinct的投票亭实际上就在这栋楼里。
And so, Nakhon-Uzalutendant started getting out the vote among people in their building. And pretty soon you can see this in the public records of turnout. Nakh's precinct would have two or three times the voting rates of all the neighboring precincts. You start seeing politicians paying attention to him, calling him on his birthday, walking him to the grocery store. And like nobody knows about this guy, right? I mean, no one in Boston outside of the political establishment, outside of his community, knows about him.
因此，诺克和他的副手开始动员他们楼里的人投票。很快你就可以从公开的投票记录中看到这一点。诺克的选区投票率将是所有邻近选区的三到两倍。你开始看到政客们开始注意他，在他生日时打电话给他，陪他去杂货店。就像没有人知道这个人一样，对吧？我的意思是，在波士顿，除了政治建制派之外，除了他的社区之外，没有人知道他。
But to his own community, he's a hero. Basically he and his wife did decades of favors for people in their community and were really nice people. They built a lot of trust and with that trust came the opportunity to influence people's votes. In other words what he was providing to his community was really a form of service. It was less about saying, here's a set of values or ideological issues that I care about. It's saying, there's a very humble way of thinking about leadership, which is, you care
但对他的社区来说，他是个英雄。基本上，他和他的妻子为社区里的人做了几十年的好事，而且人真的很好。他们建立了很多信任，随着这种信任而来的，就是影响人们投票的机会。换句话说，他为社区提供的确实是一种服务。这与其说是在表达“这是一套我所关心的价值观或意识形态问题”，不如说是在表达：这是一种非常谦逊的领导思维方式，也就是，你关心
about the potholes, I care about the potholes, you care about the snow being shoveled, I care about the snow being shoveled. And it's less about Republican versus Democrat, it's less about big issues, it's much more, I suppose it's snow being shoveled. And it's less about Republican versus Democrat. It's less about big issues. It's much more, I suppose it's much more transactional. It's much more parochial and less ideological. That's right, but even if you cared about those ideological issues mainly, even if you did, the path to getting people to care about what you care about
水坑，我也关心水坑；你关心铲雪，我也关心铲雪。这与其说是共和党对民主党，不如说是大问题，更多的是，我想这更偏向铲雪。这与其说是共和党对民主党。与其说是重大问题。这更多的是，我想这更具交易性。它更具地方色彩，而意识形态色彩较少。没错，但即使你主要关心那些意识形态问题，即使你关心，引导人们关心你在乎的事情的途径
is still Knox path. That is, if you wanted to move people on climate change, but it's hard to explain climate change, or if you want to move people on, you know, a nationalized health care, but it's really hard to explain those details. Most people are not going to want to talk to you about that, but if you're kind to them and you take them seriously and you serve their more immediate needs, then when an election comes, even by the way when there's not a celebrity on the ballot, they say, oh, I'll vote your way
仍然是诺克的途径。也就是说，如果你想让人们关注气候变化，但气候变化很难解释；或者如果你想让人们关注，你知道的，全民医保，但这些细节真的很难解释。大多数人不会想跟你谈论这个，但如果你对他们很好，认真对待他们，并满足他们更紧迫的需求，那么当选举来临时，顺便说一句，即使选票上没有名人，他们也会说，哦，我会按你的方式投票
because you, not the Ukrainian boss, I respect you. And you're telling me this thing to do, and I'll do it because maybe you know more about this than I do, or maybe I should just go along with you because you've done so many nice things for me. So whether your goals are just fixing pot holes or your goals are, you know, international climate change, the methods are very similar. The Ukrainian boss acquired power by providing basic services, food stamps,
因为你，而不是那个乌克兰老大，我尊敬你。你告诉我这么做，我就会照做，也许是因为你在这方面比我知道得更多，或者也许我应该顺从你，因为你为我做了那么多好事。所以，不管你的目标只是修补路坑，还是你的目标是，你知道的，国际气候变化，方法都是非常相似的。乌克兰老大通过提供基本服务获取了权力，比如食品券、
snow shoveling, help with a citizenship test. By contrast, political hobbyists often get involved when politics is about what Aetan calls post-materialist issues. Take the kinds of petitions that people sign. A colleague of mine, Brian Schaffner and I started looking into this petition program that the Obama administration instituted early on as administration. The idea was on the White House website you could collect digital
铲雪、协助公民考试。相比之下，政治业余爱好者往往是在政治关乎埃坦所称的“后物质主义”议题时才会参与进来。以人们签署的请愿书为例。我和我的同事布赖恩·沙夫纳开始研究奥巴马政府在其任期早期建立的这个请愿项目。当时的设想是，你可以在白宫网站上收集数字
signatures and if you got enough signatures the White House would respond to you. And you could download the data on this and so Brian Schaffner and I would download the data and we started looking at you know what kind of petitions were being signed? How many people were signing them? And we discovered something that really amazes me still, which is that most of them were about really small and mostly frivolous things. Some of them were just jokes, you know, the US should build a death star. But most of them were not like that. They were just about smaller issues,
签名，如果你收集到足够的签名，白宫就会回应你。你可以下载这些数据，于是布赖恩·沙夫纳和我下载了数据，我们开始研究，你知道的，人们都在签署什么样的请愿书？有多少人在签署？我们发现了一些至今仍让我感到惊讶的事情，那就是它们大多数都是关于非常小且大多无聊的事情。其中一些只是笑话，你知道的，美国应该建造死星。但大多数都不是那样的。它们只是关于较小的问题，
a problem of puppy mills or regulating of premium cigars. Stuff that is important, but doesn't affect the general welfare of someone who's struggling to get by. And so political scientists for a long time have noticed a shift in politics away from bread and butter issues, away from people getting food on their table and having good jobs and all that. And towards what these are called, you know, post-materialist issues,
比如虐待小狗工厂的问题或对高档雪茄的监管。这些事情很重要，但并不影响那些艰难谋生的人的总体福利。因此，政治学家长期以来一直注意到政治的一个转变：从面包黄油问题（即人们能否填饱肚子、拥有好工作等等）转向了这些被称为，你知道的，“后物质主义”的问题。
issues that are not about economic welfare or, you know, education, health, but there's other stuff. or education, health, but there's other stuff. So I want to spend a little time talking about the role of money in politics and the relationship between money and politics and the rise of what you call hobbyism. You once conducted a survey where you asked people if they'd be willing to make a donation. I think it was a thousand dollars to attend a dinner with a prominent leader. And some people were told the money would go to fund a political campaign, but others were told the money would go to an event management company and in fact would have no bearing whatsoever, no impact on policy or electoral politics. What did you find?
这些问题不涉及经济福利、教育或健康，而是其他方面。或者教育、健康，但还有别的东西。所以我想花点时间谈谈金钱在政治中的角色，金钱与政治的关系，以及你所称的“政治爱好主义”的兴起。你曾经做过一项调查，询问人们是否愿意捐款，我想是一千美元，去参加一个与知名领导人的晚宴。一些人被告知这笔钱将用于资助一场政治竞选，但另一些人被告知这笔钱将交给一家活动管理公司，实际上与政策或选举政治没有任何关系，也没有任何影响。你发现了什么？
In that survey we found that almost as many people would give a thousand dollars to have a dinner with a politician, even if the money wasn't going to the party. That is, even though in that situation, the money wouldn't be seen by the politician as something that they should reciprocate with favors, even if it didn't serve the interests of a political party or campaign, people were just willing to give money so they said to attend the dinner. And this is consistent with this general view of hobbyists in donations.
在那项调查中我们发现，几乎同样多的人愿意花一千美元去和一位政治人物共进晚餐，即使这笔钱并不是给政党的。也就是说，尽管在这种情况下，政客不会把这笔钱视为需要以恩惠回报的东西，即使它不符合某个政党或竞选活动的利益，人们也只是愿意为了参加晚宴而捐钱。这与关于捐款爱好者的普遍观点是一致的。
There was just this story in the presidential primary about Pete Buttigieg hosting an event at a wine cave. And there's events like this all over the place, exclusive events for rich donors. And the question is, are those donors giving because they want to go to an exclusive political event where they can talk about politics and take a selfie? Just in the way that my students wanted to go
总统初选中曾有过这样一个故事：皮特·布蒂吉格在酒窖举办了一场筹款活动。像这样的活动到处都是，专门针对富裕捐赠者的高端聚会。问题在于，这些捐赠者捐款是因为他们想去一个高端的政治活动，在那里谈论政治并自拍吗？就像我的学生们想要去
to New Hampshire to take a selfie with Pete Buttigieg or are they doing it to actually serve a political goal? And of course, the answer is it's both, but this survey experiment tried to allow us to say, well, okay, well, how much of it is just purely entertainment? And the thesis then from this study is that some significant portion of these big dollar donations are in fact tied to self-expression of wanting to say, I'm getting a photograph with a presidential candidate, not so much that I want some specific outcome from that candidate.
新罕布什尔州与皮特·布蒂吉格自拍一样，还是他们这样做是为了真正服务于某种政治目标？当然，答案是两者皆有，但这项调查实验试图让我们能够判断，好吧，其中纯粹属于娱乐成分的到底有多少？因此，这项研究的论点是，这些大笔捐款中相当大的一部分实际上与自我表达息息相关，也就是想要说“我正在和总统候选人合影”，而不是多么渴望从该候选人身上获得某种特定的结果。
That's right. So, these are big money donors, and as people hear what you said, they might say, all right, this tells me that small money donations are really the way to go. Those are the donations that are untainted by political hobbyism. But unfortunately, you don't agree with that, and you describe what happened when Republican Congressman Joe Wilson interrupted a state of the Union speech by President Barack Obama. First of all, remind us what happened in that incident, what followed, and what it tells us about small money donations.
没错。所以，这些是大额捐款者，当人们听到你所说的话时，可能会觉得，好吧，这说明小额捐款才是真正的康庄大道。那些才是未被政治业余爱好污染的捐款。但遗憾的是，你并不赞同这种看法，你还描述了共和党众议员乔·威尔逊打断总统巴拉克·奥巴马国情咨文演讲时发生的事情。首先，请提醒我们那起事件的经过、后续发展，以及它向我们揭示了关于小额捐款的什么道理。
Right, so Barack Obama was speaking before Congress about the health care law, and Congressman Wilson shouted at him from the seat in the House of Representatives saying, you lie. And it was a departure from the norms of kind of appropriate behavior in Congress, but soon after in the days following, Congressman Wilson earned $2 million in online donations. And this is consistent with what we see across the board in donations, which is the way to get a lot of money, if you're a politician, from small-dollar donors,
好的，当时巴拉克·奥巴马正在国会发表关于医疗保健法的演讲，众议员威尔逊在众议院的座位上冲他大喊：“你在说谎。”这背离了国会中适当行为规范的标准，但不久之后在随后的几天里，众议员威尔逊通过在线捐款赚取了200万美元。这与我们在各方捐款中看到的情况是一致的，也就是说，如果你是一名政治家，要想从微额捐款者那里获得大量资金，
is by being really provocative, by being outrageous, by doing the stuff that Donald Trump does, and it should be no surprise that the best small dollar fundraiser, you know, it's not Bernie Sanders, it's not Elizabeth Warren, it's Donald Trump. So the media by your account are both the beneficiary and the driver of political hobbyism, the encouraged people to think of politics as a sport with daily winners and daily losers, different channels for fans of different teams. And you cite clips like this one from MSNBC's Rachel Maddow.
途径就是表现得极具挑衅性，表现得骇人听闻，去做唐纳德·特朗普所做的那种事。因此，最会筹集小额资金的人不是伯尼·桑德斯，也不是伊丽莎白·沃伦，而是唐纳德·特朗普，这应该不足为奇。所以，按照你的说法，媒体既是政治业余爱好的受益者，也是其推手，它们鼓励人们把政治当作一项体育运动，有每日的赢家和每日的输家，还有针对不同球队球迷的不同频道。而且你还引用了MSNBC的雷切尔·马多节目的这样的片段。
CNN reports and we have confirmed that Manafort has now settled into sort of his forever home at FCI Loretto, which is the Federal Correctional Institute at Loretto, Pennsylvania, which is about halfway between Harrisburg and Pittsburgh. Fun fact about FCI Loretto used to be a Catholic seminary. Now what is home to Donald J. Trump presidential campaign chairman inmate number 35207-016? What is that clip, tell you Aitan? So I've learned exactly nothing from that clip, right? I've learned that Maniford went to jail.
CNN报道，并且我们已经证实，马纳福特现在已经在宾夕法尼亚州洛雷托的联邦惩教所（即FCI Loretto）安顿下来，这里大约介于哈里斯堡和布赖特堡之间。关于FCI Loretto的一个有趣的事实是，它以前是一个天主教神学院。现在，这里成了唐纳德·J·特朗普总统竞选团队主席、35207-016号犯人的住所。艾坦，这段剪辑说明了什么？所以，我从这段剪辑中什么也没有学到，对吧？我只知道马纳福特进了监狱。
I didn't need to know his present ID number. If I did, I could just look it up. It's Googleable. I didn't need to know about the details of the prison, but that sounded like Rachel Maddow was just taking me on some deep dive. There were numbers read out loud. There were facts given to me.
我不需要知道他现在的身份证号。如果需要，我可以直接查出来。谷歌一下就能找到。我不需要知道监狱的细节，但听起来雷切尔·马多就像是在带我进行某种深入探究。有一串串数字被大声读出来，还有一些事实摆在我面前。
But it doesn't in any way help me be a citizen. It doesn't help me learn how to use my role. It doesn't help me learn about how I can engage in the political process. So it's, what is it for? It's for entertainment. So we've looked at how political hobbyism can affect voters, and donors, and the media, and you've hinted at this in the past, but it also affects the behavior of politicians. What kind of positions does hobbyism encourage politicians to stake out, and perhaps just as
但它在任何方面都无助于我成为一个公民。它无助于我学习如何发挥自己的作用，也无助于我了解如何参与政治进程。所以，这是为了什么？这是为了娱乐。因此，我们已经探讨了政治业余爱好如何影响选民、捐赠者和媒体，你过去也暗示过这一点，但它也影响了政治家的行为。业余爱好鼓励政治家采取什么样的立场，也许同样重要的是，
importantly, what kind of positions does it discourage them from exploring? So the main thing it does is it encourages politicians to respond to the short-term demands for instant gratification that the hobbyists want. If you know that the way to make a lot of money in small-dollar donations is to be very provocative, to get a viral video of yourself yelling at someone, then that's what you're going to do. That's what you're going to do in an impeachment hearing or a hearing for a Supreme Court justice nominee. That's what we're going to do in the debate stage. You know, we had this moment early in
它阻止他们探讨什么样的立场？所以它产生的主要影响是，它鼓励政治家去迎合业余爱好者们对即时满足的短期需求。如果你知道在小额捐款中筹集大量资金的方法就是表现得极具挑衅性，搞出一个自己对别人大吼大叫的病毒视频，那么这正是你会做的事。在弹劾听证会或最高法院大法官提名听证会上，你也会这么做。我们在辩论台上也会这样做。你知道，我们在早期的大选初选辩论中经历过这样的时刻：
the presidential primary debate where Kamala Harris went after Joe Biden very harshly about this issue of busing. And it turned out the policy differences between them weren't that big. It wasn't clear in the end what Senator Harris position was. But immediately after that debate, Senator Harris raised a ton of money online for people who were excited to see her, so-called, destroy Joe Biden. And so if we, the hobbyists, give that incentive to politicians, and that's how they're going to behave.
卡马拉·哈里斯就校车接送问题对乔·拜登进行了严厉的抨击。结果证明，他们之间的政策分歧其实并没有那么大。到最后，人们也不清楚哈里斯参议员的立场到底是什么。但就在那场辩论结束后不久，哈里斯参议员通过网络为那些看到她“痛击乔·拜登”而兴奋不已的人筹集了巨额资金。所以，如果我们这些业余爱好者给政治家提供这种激励，他们就会那样行事。
You mentioned Donald Trump a second ago. I want to play you a short clip of President Donald Trump speaking at a rally in North Carolina some time ago where he singled out a democratic congresswoman, Representative Ilhan Omar. of launching vicious anti-Semitic screens. So when you listen to a clip like this, Eitan, you know, obviously the crowd is very energized by what President Trump is saying, but of course it also energizes people on the left who believe he's singling out a Congresswoman,
你刚才提到了唐纳德·特朗普。我想播放一小段录音，是唐纳德·特朗普总统不久前在北卡罗来纳州的一次集会上发表的讲话，他在讲话中点名了一位民主党女国会议员，即伊尔han·奥马尔众议员。她发表了恶毒的反犹太主义言论。所以，艾坦，当你听到这样的片段时，很显然，特朗普总统的言论极大地鼓舞了现场的群众，但当然，这也激怒了左翼人士，他们认为他在单挑一位女国会议员、
a woman of color, treating her especially badly. And in some ways, it's a textbook example of how one comment from the president can trigger hobbyism on both sides. That's right. First of all, that whole scene of the president Trump going to a rally and all those people chanting against Representative Omar, responding to Trump, singling her out, is really a classic example of the parallel between what's happening in politics and what happened in sports. I mean, it feels like a sports stadium saying Yankee suck. It feels like that and it feels like it can be dangerous, just like we have
一位有色人种女性，对她极其恶劣。在某些方面，这堪称一个教科书式的例子，说明总统的一番言论如何在双方阵营中引发业余爱好式的狂热。没错。首先，特朗普总统去参加集会、所有人都在高喊反对奥马尔众议员并回应特朗普的点名这一整幕，确实是政治与体育之间相似性的一个典型例子。我的意思是，这感觉就像体育场里高喊“洋基队去死”一样。这种感觉不仅如此，而且可能很危险，就像我们在世界各地看到的那样。
around the world. Sports arena chance like that turning into violence. It can happen in politics too. of violence. It can happen in politics too. And on the left, we also have maybe a day after that of Twitter responses. And instead of spending time on thinking about what a voter can do as a citizen, or not just thinking about, but taking some action, we're wasting all energy on both sides arguing about this thing. I want you to read an excerpt from your book. I think this is on page 82 toward the bottom. It's the paragraph starting. So there it is. In many ways, I think it sums up what we've been talking about the last half an hour or so. So there it is. What news do political junkies demand?
体育场里的那种呐喊演变成暴力。政治中也可能会发生这种情况。暴力事件。政治中也可能会发生这种情况。而在左翼阵营，可能在第二天也会看到推特上的各种回应。我们没有把时间花在思考选民作为一个公民能做些什么上，或者不仅仅是思考，而是采取一些行动，反而把所有的精力都浪费在双方对这件事的争吵上。我想请你读一下你书中的一个摘录。我想这大约在第82页的下半部分。就是以“所以，就是这样”开头的那个段落。在许多方面，我认为它总结了我们过去半小时左右一直在讨论的内容。所以，就是这样。政治狂热分子渴望什么样的资讯？
Outrage and gossip. Why? Because it's a learning. What news do we avoid? Local news. Why? It's boring. What do we think of our partisan opponents?
愤怒和八卦。为什么？因为这是一种学习。我们回避什么样的资讯？地方新闻。为什么？因为它很无聊。我们如何看待我们的党派对手？
We hate them. Do we really hate them? No. But politics is more fun if we root for a team and spew anger at the other side. It's easier to hate and dismiss the other side than to empathize and connect to them. When do we vote? When there's a spectacle. When do we click? When politics can be a frivolous distraction. When do we donate? When there's a cocktail party or a viral video. What are we doing? We're taking actions not to empower our political values, but to satisfy
我们讨厌他们。我们真的讨厌他们吗？不。但如果我们支持一支球队并向另一方倾泻怒气，政治就会变得更有趣。恨并轻视另一方，总比同理他们、与他们建立联系要容易。我们什么时候投票？当有热闹可看的时候。我们什么时候点击？当政治可以成为一种轻率的消遣时。我们什么时候捐款？当有鸡尾酒会或病毒视频时。我们在做什么？我们采取行动不是为了赋能我们的政治价值观，而是为了满足
our passion for the sport of politics. When we come back, even as many political hobbyists expand their energies on the latest outrage on Twitter, Eitan Hirsch argues there are other people who are very serious about acquiring and wielding power. These are the people who end up shaping policy. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Political scientist Aetan Hirsch makes the case that many Americans engage in politics in the same way that sports fans engage with their teams, as a form of entertainment and self-expression. with their teams as a form of entertainment and self-expression. At the same time, people who are more serious about acquiring and wielding power are quietly
我们对政治这项运动的热情。稍后回来，尽管许多政治业余爱好者将精力消耗在推特上的最新愤怒上，但艾坦·赫什认为，还有其他人对获取和行使权力非常认真。正是这些人最终塑造了政策。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。政治学家艾坦·赫什提出，许多美国人参与政治的方式与体育迷支持他们球队的方式如出一辙，将其视为一种娱乐和自我表达的形式。将其球队视为一种娱乐和自我表达的形式。与此同时，那些更认真于获取和行使权力的人正悄悄地
going in a different direction. Eitan says that in 2018, the Ku Klux Klan made the rounds in North Carolina. The group wasn't talking to people about racial issues, but something else entirely. There were news reports that the Ku Klux Kahn North Carolina was going around with flyers targeting opioid addicts and saying, you know, do you have an addiction? It's not your fault. And we hear at the White Knights, the KKK can help you through it. Why would they do that?
走向不同的方向。艾坦说，2018年，三K党在北卡罗来纳州四处活动。这个组织并没有跟人们谈论种族问题，而是完全谈论别的事情。有新闻报道称，北卡罗来纳州的三K党带着传单四处走动，目标直指阿片类药物成瘾者，他们说：“你知道吗，你上瘾了吗？这不是你的错。我们白骑士（三K党的分支）可以帮你度过难关。”他们为什么要这么做？
I think they would do that because they know their path to getting more recruits, to building political power, is not necessarily by telling people that they have this hateful ideology, but by saying, hey, we're going to take care of people. And if no one else is taking care of people who are suffering from addiction, then they're going to get some people on their side. In many ways, it's actually the model of the Ukrainian boss, right? It's basically asking, not how do I bring people over to where I am, or at least not asking that question at first, but really asking people, where are you? What are the issues that you care about? What's happening in your life? How can I be
我认为他们这样做是因为他们知道，获取更多新成员、建立政治权力的途径，不一定是通过告诉人们他们拥有这种充满仇恨的意识形态，而是通过说：“嘿，我们会照顾好人们。”如果其他人不去照顾那些饱受毒瘾折磨的人，那么他们就会把一些人拉拢到自己这一边。在很多方面，这其实就是乌克兰老板的模式，对吧？它基本上问的不是“我如何把人们拉到我这边来”，或者至少一开始不问这个问题，而是真正地去问人们：“你在哪里？你关心什么问题？你的生活中发生了什么？我怎么能
of help to you in dealing with these issues, in forming a connection with people, and then bringing them over and say, you know, we obviously have this connection, you should support me on this thing that I care a lot about. That's right. I think everyone who cares about politics, even if you're, you know, the classic hobbyist, you want to help people. And the question is, how do you do it? And what you see across the political spectrum, from the far right, you also see it across
在处理这些问题、与人们建立联系方面帮到你，然后再把他们拉过来并说：‘你知道，我们显然有这种联系，你应该在我非常关心的这件事上支持我。’”没错。我认为每个关心政治的人，即使你是个典型的业余爱好者，你也想帮助别人。问题在于，你该怎么做？你在整个政治光谱中都能看到这一点，从极右翼，你也能在
the world in groups like Hamas that have gained power in the Arab world. You see people saying, okay, we're not going to necessarily talk to you about ideology because A, policies complicated in ideology, you might not agree with us in everything. Instead, what we're going to do is we're going to try to take care of you. I remember the conversation I had with the anthropologist Scott Atron and he has studied the rise of groups such as ISIS. He told me that even though the group might have these really radical goals, the immediate practical thing they do is not talk about the destruction of infadels, but really they
世界各地的类似哈马斯这样在阿拉伯世界获得权力的组织中看到这一点。你会看到人们说：“好吧，我们不一定会跟你谈意识形态，因为A，政策和意识形态很复杂，你可能不会在所有事情上都同意我们的看法。相反，我们要做的就是努力照顾好你。”我记得我曾与人类学家斯科特·阿特兰有过一次交谈，他研究过诸如“伊斯兰国”等组织的崛起。他告诉我，尽管该组织可能拥有非常激进的目标，但他们采取的直接实际行动不是谈论消灭异教徒，而是切实地
provide social services, educational services, a safety net, and the very kind of practical parochial issues that cause people to say, this is a group that really cares about us. That's right, and this is what political parties used to do. Back in the day, when they were giving out, you know, free turkeys and vaccine shots and serving needs that the government eventually picked up, some of those needs, but they were, the political parties were the ones doing it. You see that's what Knox doing, taking care of people. You have an interesting suggestion for both the Republican Party and the Democratic Party and it's based on something that you noticed at Tufts University where
提供社会服务、教育服务、安全网，以及那些非常实际的、地方性的问题，正是这些问题让人们觉得：“这是一个真正关心我们的组织。”没错，这正是政党过去常常做的事情。在过去，当他们分发免费火鸡和疫苗注射，并满足政府最终接手的一些需求时，虽然其中一些需求由政府接手，但当时是政党在做这些事。你看，诺克斯（Nox）就是这样做的，照顾人民。你对共和党和民主党都有一个有趣的建议，它是基于你在你工作的塔夫茨大学注意到的一件事，
you work, where your school offers faculty members back up child care. What was the idea? So the idea is that, you know, where I work at Tufts, if I ever can't, if you know, I have three little kids, so this obviously really spoke to me, but this also is true if you have elderly parents that you're taking care of. If you ever need backup care, you can go to this website and Tophs will highly subsidize emergency backup care for something like 20 days a year. Now, I've never used this benefit personally, but it's important to me that it's there. It shows that the university cares about people who are taking care of their kids or taking care of elderly parents and Those who use it really do benefit from it
你们学校为教职员工提供备用托儿服务。这是什么主意？这个想法是，你知道，我在塔夫茨工作，如果我什么时候不能……你知道，我有三个小孩子，所以这个想法显然深深打动了我，但如果你有需要照顾的老年父母，这也是一样的。如果你什么时候需要备用照护，你可以访问这个网站，塔夫茨大学将为每年大约20天的紧急备用照护提供高额补贴。现在，我个人从来没有使用过这项福利，但它能放在那里对我来说很重要。这表明学校关心那些照顾孩子或照顾年迈父母的人，而那些使用它的人确实受益匪浅。
My suggestion was imagining political parties doing things like that providing emergency child care and emergency Elder care maybe contracting with one of these companies that do this. And by doing that, they're saying, hey, we have some big policy goals here, you know, maybe on the democratic side, we really care about getting family leave passed in this country. And it might take us a little while to do that. But in the meantime, what we're going to do is we're going to show you as concretely as possible that we care about you and we care about these needs. And the way we're gonna do that is instead of sending you endless ads about how great we are, call us if you need a problem. Tell us. Are you going through something where you need an emergency backup,
我的建议是想象政党做类似的事情，提供紧急托儿服务和紧急老人护理，也许可以与提供这项服务的公司之一签约。通过这样做，他们是在说：“嘿，我们这里有一些宏大的政策目标，你知道，也许在民主党这边，我们真的很关心在这个国家通过带薪家庭假。这可能需要我们花一点时间来实现。但在此期间，我们要做的就是尽可能具体地向你表明，我们关心你，我们也关心这些需求。我们要做的方式不是向我们发送无数关于我们有多伟大的广告，如果你遇到问题就给我们打电话。告诉我们。你是否正在经历需要紧急备用托儿服务、老人护理服务的情况，你是否正在经历戒毒问题？”
child care provider, elder care provider, are you going through an addiction problem? Political parties should be at the forefront of solving these problems. And would this even be legal to do? So yeah, it's complicated. It's going to be a different state by state. But right now, there is a broad ability for parties to engage in what are called party building activities. They're not allowed to trade favors or give assistance in exchange for a vote in election. But they're allowed to do stuff that promotes their party brand that says, hey, where the
政党应该站在解决这些问题的前沿。这样做甚至合法吗？是的，这很复杂。不同州的情况会不同。但目前，政党有广泛的能力参与所谓的“政党建设活动”。他们不允许为了选举中的一张选票而进行利益交换或提供援助。但他们被允许做一些宣传其政党品牌的事情，比如：“嘿，我们是
Democratic Party or where the Republican Party and we care about you and you should like our brand. And we can run a pancake breakfast, we can host a carnival, we can do a whole bunch of stuff that is for that purpose. This is within the historical role of what a political party is supposed to do. So there are people who are clearly taking to heart the ideas that you're talking about in the book. You cite the example of an activist named Dave Fleischer. When he goes around canvassing, he tells people a personal story about his high school girlfriend. What's the story, Etan, and why does Dave tell people that story?
民主党或共和党，我们关心你，你应该喜欢我们的品牌。”我们可以举办煎饼早餐会，可以举办嘉年华，我们可以为了这个目的做一大堆事情。这完全在政党应该发挥的历史角色之内。所以，确实有人把你在书中谈到的理念铭记在心。你引用了一位名叫戴夫·弗莱彻的活动家的例子。当他挨家挨户拉票时，他会向人们讲述一个关于他的高中女友的个人故事。这是一个什么样的故事，艾坦？为什么戴夫要向人们讲述这个故事？
So Dave tells the story of his high school girlfriend, and this very intimate story, really, about how he had a high school girlfriend to begin with. We later learned that Dave is gay and knew he was gay from the time he was a kid. And he had a high school girlfriend because in high school that's how he's supposed to do to fit in. This is the 1970s. And he and his girlfriend weren't having sex
所以戴夫讲述了他高中女友的故事，这是一个非常私人的故事，讲述了他当初是怎么交到一个高中女友的。我们后来得知戴夫是个同性恋，而且他从还是个孩子的时候就知道自己是同性恋。他之所以交了一个高中女友，是因为在高中时，为了融入集体就该这么做。那是20世纪70年代。他和他的女友并没有发生性关系，
and he talks about that publicly and he talks about the fact that he didn't want to have sex with her. And she in the end felt bad that like what was wrong with her. And he tells the story to strangers at the door. Maybe he's canvassing on behalf of abortion rights. And he's saying, you know, I'm a gay man. What do I know about abortion rights?
他公开谈论了这一点，并谈到了他其实不想和她发生性关系的事。最后她感到很难过，觉得是不是自己出了什么问题。他把这个故事讲给敲门遇到的陌生人听。也许他是在为堕育权拉票。他说：“你知道，我是一个同性恋男子。我对堕育权了解多少？
Well, I can tell you a story that really speaks to me about why I take approach choice position. And then by approach choice comes from position of understanding all the complicated reasons why people have sex, why people might accidentally get pregnant, all the awkwardness of and discomfort of being a young person, figuring themselves out. And you know, got for a bid that he did have sex with girlfriend and she got pregnant You know later he had been hiding the fact that he was gay. It's you know a complicated situation And he tells that story to someone who maybe it's Republican to someone who is pro life as
嗯，我可以给你讲一个真正触动我的故事，讲述我为什么采取支持堕育选择的立场。然后，我支持选择的立场来自于对所有复杂原因的理解：为什么人们会有性行为，为什么人们可能会意外怀孕，以及作为一个正在摸索自己的年轻人所经历的各种尴尬和不适。你知道，如果他真的和女友发生了性关系并且她怀孕了（上帝保密），后来他一直在隐瞒自己是同性恋的事实。你知道，这是一个复杂的情况。”他把这个故事讲给某个可能是共和党人、某个反堕育的人听，
A way to tell that person like hey, this is where I come from this is why like deep in my heart I have this value and Tell me about you and where you come from on an issue like like deep in my heart, I have this value. And tell me about you. And where you come from on an issue like this. And he tells the story, Dave tells the story to try to make a connection. Because on a lot of issues, the person at the other side of that door might not have a strongly held view or might have a view that changes in light of a story like Dave shares. Maybe they're really strongly positioned on this issue, and they're never going to, you
以此来告诉那个人：“嘿，这就是我的背景，这就是为什么在我内心深处我有这种价值观，也告诉我关于你以及你在这样一个问题上的背景。”在我内心深处，我有这种价值观。也告诉我关于你。以及你在这样一个问题上的背景。他讲述这个故事，戴夫讲述这个故事是为了建立联系。因为在许多问题上，门另一边的那个人可能没有坚定的观点，或者其观点可能会因为戴夫分享的故事而改变。也许他们在这个问题上立场非常坚定，而且他们永远不会朝
know, they're never really going to move on it in Dave's direction. At least maybe they've built some mutual understanding with one another, Dave and the person at the door. On the other hand, it might be that this is the person who wasn't sure what they thought or had mixed feelings, and Dave's intimate story, Dave's story about his personal life helps them see why this is so important to him. Dave's method is to say, well, let me be vulnerable to you. Let me open myself up to you.
戴夫的方向转变。至少，戴夫和门那边的人可能已经建立了一些相互理解。另一方面，这个人可能还不确定自己的想法，或者有着复杂的情绪，而戴夫的私密故事、关于他个人生活的的故事有助于他们理解为什么这件事对他是如此重要。戴夫的方法是：“好吧，让我向你展现我的脆弱。让我向你敞开心扉。”
And in return, maybe you might do the same. And you might better understand why I'm talking to you about politics today. I'm wondering if you can talk a little bit about the fact that this approach, which is sometimes called deep canvassing, was initially received with some skepticism in the academic community, but you say there has been subsequent work that has reestablished the value of this technique. Yeah, this was a strange situation for the discipline of political science, the initial studies of this were done
作为回报，也许你也会这样做。这样你就能更好地理解为什么我今天要跟你谈论政治。我想请你谈谈这样一个事实：这种有时被称为“深度拉票”的方法最初在学术界遭到了一些怀疑，但你说后续的研究已经重新确立了这项技术的价值。是的，对于政治学学科来说，这是一个奇怪的局面，最初关于这方面的研究是由
by this grad student who ended up fabricating the data. And so the initial results, which were very highly publicized, were all retracted. The study was retracted. It was very embarrassing. But the people who discovered the problem discovered it because they wanted to actually do it too. They discovered all these irregularities in discovered it because they wanted to actually do it too. They discovered all these irregularities in the data when they tried to replicate what they were doing. So after the scandal broke, these same scholars did a new study that wasn't obviously fabricated, that was very rigorously done.
一个最后篡改了数据的研究生完成的。因此，那些最初被大肆宣传的研究结果全部被撤回了。这项研究被撤回了。这非常尴尬。但是发现问题的人之所以发现，是因为他们自己也想这样做。他们在试图复制对方的做法时，发现了数据中的所有这些不规则之处。因此在丑闻爆发后，这些学者做了一项新的研究，这项研究显然没有被篡改，而且做得很严谨。
And they found similar results, that is that the deep canvassing is very effective. It's particularly effective at this, at this very hard task of persuasion. The reason to do deep canvassing is not to remind people to vote. It's pretty easy to remind someone to vote. It's very hard to convince someone to change their mind about an issue. And so deep canvassing is one of the most effective ways, if not the most effective way,
他们发现了类似的结果，也就是说深度拉票非常有效。在说服这项非常困难的任务上，它特别有效。进行深度拉票的原因不是为了提醒人们去投票。提醒别人去投票其实挺容易的。但要说服别人改变对某个问题的看法却非常难。因此，深度拉票是最有效的方法之一，如果不是最有效的方法的话，
to do that. Now it's time-consuming, it's hard to train people, it's hard to give and people to do this very awkward thing, but in the end it's effective. So 2020 promises to be an intensely heated year when it comes to politics, and no matter what happens in the 2020 presidential election, it seems more or less certain that millions of people on the losing side are going to feel their fellow citizens have betrayed America and betrayed fundamental American values. The idea that ordinary people should reach out to their opponents, reach out empathetically, I'm wondering if a lot of people are going to say, you know, Aitan, that sounds like a pipe dream.
来做到这一点。现在它很耗时，培训人员很难，让人们去做这种非常尴尬的事情很难，但最终它是有效的。因此，2020年注定是一个政治气氛极其紧张的一年，无论2020年美国总统大选结果如何，可以肯定的是，失败一方的数百万选民或多或少都会觉得他们的同胞背叛了美国，背叛了美利坚的基本价值观。关于普通人应该向他们的对手伸出援手、带着同理心去接触的观点，我想很多人会说：“你知道吗，艾坦，听起来这就像是个白日梦。”
I think quite the opposite. It's the only thing you can do. This book is written for someone who wants to understand their role in our democracy. Their role is not to follow what Trump does. No one is depending on them to follow the news about Donald Trump's tweets. No one is depending on them to have a hot take on Facebook. But there are ways in which they can be in communities where people are depending on them, depending on them to get to a meeting, to show up, to move policy in their direction.
我觉得恰恰相反。这是你唯一能做的事。这本书是为那些想要理解自己在民主政体中的角色的人写的。他们的角色不是去关注特朗普在做什么。没有人指望他们去关注关于唐纳德·特朗普推特的动态。也没有人指望他们在脸书上发表激进的言论。但在某些方面，他们可以身处这样的社群中：人们依赖他们，依赖他们去参加会议、出席活动、推动政策朝他们期望的方向发展。
If they really care about something like climate change, guess what? The regional transportation system in their state might sound boring, but it's pretty important to solving that problem, and they, as a citizen by themselves and the group that's organized locally, can have a role to play in that. They can help their own neighbors move forward on some issues that they care about. They have no role to play in the national political scene. Yes, they can vote. But no one needs them. The country doesn't need them to follow Twitter. But I would say that the point of this book is that to tell the reader, hey, like your country
如果他们真的很关心气候变化之类的事情，你猜怎么着？他们所在州的区域交通系统听起来可能很无聊，但对于解决这个问题却相当重要，而他们，作为一个独立的公民以及在当地组织起来的团体，可以在其中发挥作用。他们可以帮助自己的邻居在某些他们关心的问题上取得进展。他们在国家政治舞台上发挥不了什么作用。是的，他们可以投票。但没有人需要他们。国家不需要他们去关注推特。不过我想说的是，这本书的重点是告诉读者：“嘿，你的国家
really does need you to do something, and it's not going to be following Twitter. It's going to be talking to your neighbors, building a community, getting organized, moving policy, doing what Nachtas, trying to get a thousand people to do what you want to do. Eitan Hirsch is a political scientist at Tufts University. He's the author of Politics is for power, how to move beyond political hobbyism, take action, and make real change. Aitan, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks very much. This week's show was produced by Path Shah and Lu Shik Waba, and edited by Tara Boyle
确实需要你做点什么，而且这不会是关注推特。而是跟你的邻居交谈、建立社群、组织起来、推动政策、做诺克斯正在做的事——试着让一千个人去做你想让他们做的事。”艾坦·赫什是塔夫茨大学的政治学家。他是《政治是为权力服务的：如何超越政治业余爱好、采取行动并做出真正改变》一书的作者。艾坦，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢。今天的节目由帕特·沙阿和卢希克·瓦巴制作，由塔拉·博伊尔
and Raina Cohen. Engineering support from Andy Huthur and Patrick Boyd. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarelle and Kat Schuchnick. Fact-checking is a crucial element of the work we do on every episode of Hidden Brain. That's why our unsung hero today is Barkley Walsh. Barkley is a fact checker at NPR and she helped us verify some of the claims we made in today's show. Thank you Barkley.
和雷娜·科恩剪辑。工程支持来自安迪·胡瑟和帕特里克·博伊德。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、托马斯·刘、劳拉·夸雷莱和卡特·舒奇尼克。事实核查是我们对《隐藏的大脑》每一集节目工作中的核心环节。这就是为什么我们今天的无名英雄是巴克利·沃尔什。巴克利是NPR的事实核查员，她协助我们核实了今天节目中提出的一些主张。谢谢你，巴克利。
If you enjoyed today's episode, please share it with a friend or neighbor. Better yet, share it with someone you don't know well and start a new conversation. Before we go, we're looking for your help with a future episode. So many people have done something in the past that has come to haunt them for the rest of their lives. Maybe you did something wrong and you can't forgive yourself. Or maybe it's others who can't forgive you. Or perhaps the thing you did in the past was so brilliant and well received that it's come to pigeonhole you. Yours later, for what good and bad, you can barely identify with this old version of yourself, but to
如果你喜欢今天的节目，请把它分享给朋友或邻居。更好的是，把它分享给你不太熟悉的人，并开启一段新的对话。在结束之前，我们希望你能协助我们完成未来的一集节目。很多人在过去都做过一些事情，这些事后来一直困扰着他们。也许你做错了事，却无法原谅自己。或者也许是别人无法原谅你。又或者你过去做的那件事是如此辉煌且广受好评，以至于把你框定在了一个狭隘的形象里。多年以后，无论是好是坏，你几乎都无法认同这个旧版本的自己，但对于
many other people, that stranger is still you. If you have a story like this and are willing to share it with us, please find a quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at hiddenbrain at npr.org. Use the subject line, haunted. Haunted. That email again, hiddenbrain at npr.org. I'm Shankar Vidantum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
许多其他人来说，那个陌生人依然是你。如果你有这样的故事并愿意与我们分享，请找一个安静的房间，在手机上录下一段语音备忘录，然后发电子邮件给我们，邮箱是 hiddenbrain@npr.org。主题行请写：被困扰（haunted）。再重复一遍邮箱地址：hiddenbrain@npr.org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本集节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。